so something that is been on my mind and
I wanted to make a quick video about is
I've been reading so many of the
comments on social networks about these
teenagers these kids they don't get it
they're always on their phone I you know
I'm blown away by the establishment by
parents by the market by the elders and
even by some of the kids within the age
demo of the gross underestimation of
this 11 to 16 year old this 10 to 19
year old demo what world do you think
they're going to be living in in 2025
and so all these critiques you have
about what they're doing and they're not
socially this and they're not good
enough and they don't work hard enough I
don't know what you're paying attention
to watching these kids grind and hustle
and create content and ideas and
businesses in these social networks why
don't you shut the [ __ ] up and go to
Instagram for three hours and stop
judging and pay attention to the
explosion of this creative hustler class
that is the teenagers and the dominant
leaders of our future